if you want to make a million dollars
you've got to do something you're
passionate about you have to build a
business that excites you and also helps
people otherwise you're never going to
make you're not going to hit that
financial goal and the entrepreneurs who
just started business to try to make
money never do hi I'm Evan Carmichael
I believe that hungry entrepreneur's
deserve help and today mention a
question from one of my YouTube viewers
guy thanks guy grow it insane in your
opinion what's the best way to reach a
million dollars in 20 years let's say I
have no particular skill or education
which is not true in my case and I have
20,000 dollars in savings so guy first
of all hey 20 years is a long time you
don't have to wait that belt that long
you can make your million a lot faster
than that I want to see you dream bigger
and it doesn't matter how much you have
in savings
doesn't matter you've twenty thousand
dollars a hundred thousand dollars half
a million it doesn't matter what matters
is if you're starting a business you
build it around something that you
believe in something you love doing
something that you can get lost in you
wake up at 9:00 in the morning and
you're working away and it's 5:00 at
night and you're still you wonder where
the time went
like you got to love it you got to love
your business you may not love every
aspect about your business but you have
to love what you're doing and it has to
help people it has to have an impact
because people will pay you to help them
the more you're helping them the more
they're going to pay you you want to get
paid quickly with a lot of money then
offer a lot of value really quickly
that's business so I don't know what
your interests are it doesn't matter so
much what your education is it doesn't
matter what you're starting from if you
look at some of the most successful
entrepreneurs in the world
they had no savings they had no
education and they built up huge
businesses the stuff doesn't matter in
the entrepreneurial world it doesn't
matter if you're trying to get a job
then your education matters but it's not
as important as a business owner what's
important is you're starting a company
around something that you passionately
believe it like you love this I love
helping entrepreneurs it's what I love
doing at first I didn't know how I was
gonna make money doing it making this
video I'm not making money doing this
you asking me a question and I'm
spending my time
because I love doing it when I'm making
these videos one of the best parts of my
week I'm passionate about hopefully that
comes through when I'm talking to you in
the videos I really love doing this and
I found ways to make money doing it and
the more I help people the more money I
make but I didn't start it just to make
money because you're going to quit as
soon as it gets hard and it's going to
get hard I started it because I love
doing it and I found a way to make it
work and to make me build a living off
of it and build a successful company off
of it so that's my advice and I think
you can do it faster than 20-years
good luck for those of you watching you
like the video please give it a thumbs
up below makes me to do more for you and
love to hear we have to think about this
video in the comments below or if you
have a question for your own business
feel free to leave in the comment
section below thank you and I'll see you
on the next episode